I'm retiring well in that case what are
we drinking same for the goddaughter God
told me you found something
trained during the war
a dial that could change the course of
history why are you chasing the thing
that drove your father crazy
he'll move please get out of here
sorry
it's yours get him
[Music]
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all you stole it then
you stole it and then I stole it it's
called capitalism
[Music]
fasten your seat belt there might be
some tablets you've taken your chances
made your mistakes
and now a final Triumph
Indie give him hell Indiana Jones a few
times in my life we've seen things
I've been tortured with Voodoo
been shot nine times
included once by your father
ah sorry
and I've been looking for this
all my life
[Music]